hypocrisy is an extremely common and
unsurprising characteristic of leaders
they say one thing but do another they
apply different standards to different
people and different groups normally
however this hypocrisy is rooted in
giving special privileges to themselves
and their parties we've got the power so
let's use it to our advantage but a
completely different kind of hypocrisy
is on Full display in Great Britain this
hypocrisy is rooted in racism and
bigotry and hate and outright Insanity
let's have a look Vivid posted on X here
starmer claims that the problem in
England is
islamophobia is this a joke islamophobia
is no joke Vivid so instead of
dismissing prime minister Kier starmer's
heartfelt distress the product of his
perfectly functioning moral compass
perhaps you should hear him out we've
seen a devastating rise in islamophobia
leaving people feeling fearful and
unsafe in their own country well it's
good that Kier starmer is worried about
people feeling fearful and unsafe in
their own country imagine people feeling
fearful and unsafe in their own
neighborhood their own City their own
country awful alarming appalling I've
heard firsthand of women wearing hijab
who are too scared to travel by public
transport women and girls are scared to
travel in C certain areas glad kir
starmer is taking the concerns of women
and girls so seriously imagine a modern
Western Nation where women and girls are
scared to travel in certain places
because of the way they might be treated
by people who despise them what kind of
sick culture would mistreat a woman or a
girl based on what she wears on her head
of Muslim families being abused as they
leave the mosque the surge in
islamophobia is simply appalling Muslim
women and girls disproportionately
targeted mosques forced to ramp up
security and British Muslims questioned
as if they are terrorists wow treating
people like terrorists just because of
their beliefs what's happening in the
UK I do not want Britain to be a place
where British Muslims are not able to be
their whole selves where they feel they
must hide or tone down who they are
every time I've been to Great Britain it
was burka as as far as the eye could see
I had no idea that Muslims are so
oppressed that they're being forced to
tone down who they are shame on Great
Britain why would anyone want to move
there our Britain is one where the
enormous contributions of British
Muslims are recognized and celebrated
their stories heard their lives free
from
discrimination as leader of the labor
party I am indebted to the contributions
of Muslim members activists and
politicians who make our party what it
is today my goodness after contributing
so many good things to British Society
like making the labor party what it is
today and probably some other things it
sounds like Muslims are running for
their lives as non-muslims chase them
through the streets after hearing Kier
starmer's little speech Great Britain
sounds like the most evil racist place
in the entire world no wonder the elites
who despise it so much are all too happy
to see it destroyed so vivid shared that
on X and I reposted it and added a
Muslim says I'm scared of these people
around me here starmer replies you have
my full support but when a non-muslim
says I'm scared of these people around
me K starma replies then you're going to
prison you racist scum and that's why
they call him two-tier care I'm not very
big on X but my post got 32,000 likes
and 8,000 shares seems like there are a
lot of people who are disturbed by
two-tier K's two-tier
approach if a Muslim in Great Britain
says I'm concerned about the spread of
islamophobia I'm afraid of the people
who are spreading it I don't feel safe
police are going to show up at the
muslim's door those police officers are
going to reply tell us who's bothering
you so we can go arrest them if
non-muslim in Great Britain says I'm
concerned about the spread of Islam I'm
afraid of the people who are spreading
it I don't feel safe police are going to
show up at the non-muslims door those
police officers are going to reply grab
your blood pressure Med's Grandpa
because you're going to
prison why are some people's feelings
valid while other people's aren't why
are some people in Great Britain free to
express their worries while other people
aren't this reminds me of a New York
Times article I read back in 2016 the
article was written by comedian and
actor Aziz Ansari and it was titled why
Trump makes me scared for my family Aziz
writes don't go anywhere near a mosque I
told my mother do all your prayer at
home okay we're not going she replied I
am the son of Muslim immigrants as I
sent that text in the aftermath of the
horrible attack in Orlando Florida I
realized how awful it was to tell an
American citizen to be careful about how
she woried he's referring to the Pulse
Nightclub shooting in Orlando where
American Jihadi Omar matin killed 49
people in the name of Allah so a Jihadi
killed dozens of non-muslims and Aziz
Ansari was worried about his Muslim
family who for some reason are the real
victims in this article aiz continues
today with the presidential candidate
Donald J Trump and others like him
spewing hate speech Prejudice is
reaching new levels it's visceral and
scary and it affects how people live
work and pray it makes me afraid for my
family it also makes no sense he was
afraid for his family because Trump and
others like him were spewing hate speech
so it's okay to be scared of trump
supporters but Aziz insists that fear of
Muslims is totally irrational here's why
there are approximately 3.3 million
Muslim Americans after the attack in
Orlando the times reported that the FBI
is investigating 1,000 potential
homegrown violent extremists a majority
of whom are most likely connected in
some way to the Islamic State if
everyone on that list is Muslim American
that is
0.03% of the Muslim ameran population if
you round that number it is 0% the
overwhelming number of Muslim Americans
have as much in common with that monster
in Orlando as any white person has with
any of the white terrorists who shoot up
movie theaters or schools or abortion
clinics think about what Aziz just said
because it's the same hypocrisy we see
from K starmer Aziz says it's only a
tiny minority of our group who support
the Islamic State so your concerns about
our group are irrational your fears are
irrational he says this in an article
about how scared he is of trump and his
supporters just for clarification what
percentage of trump supporters were
going around killing aziz's family
members or any other
Muslims I'm not aware of any but for the
sake of argument let's just say it was a
really really tiny
percentage according to aiz is it
rational to be scared of an entire group
based on the actions of a tiny
percentage of that group let me ask that
again because the hypocrisy lies in the
answer according to Aziz is it rational
to be scared of an entire group based on
the actions of a tiny percentage of that
group if you're Muslim yes if you're
non-muslim no if you're a Muslim and no
one's attacking you you're entirely
justified in being scared because
someone in the group you're worried
about may be coming to get you if you're
a non-muslim and a bunch of non-muslims
were just killed by a Jihadi you're
entirely unjustified in being scared
because it's only a tiny minority who
actually want to kill you let me put
this differently according to aiz it
makes perfect sense for Muslims to be
afraid of trump supporters why because
Trump said some mean things and he has a
lot of followers okay so it's perfectly
rational to be afraid of a group of
people who follow some Authority who
said some mean things that's the rule
according to aiz right so when I open
the Quran and I read about Allah's
command in Surah 9: 29 to fight those
who do not believe in Allah or his
command in Surah 9:23 to fight those of
the unbelievers who are near to you and
let them find in you hardness or his
declaration in Surah
48:29 that Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah and those who are with him are
severe against disbelievers and merciful
among themselves and I understand that
Allah has a lot of followers am I
allowed to be at all concerned no
because I'm not a Muslim only Muslims
are allowed to be concerned when a group
says things about them that was aiz
Ansari back in 2016 but things are much
much worse in Great Britain in 2 because
the hypocrisy has taken over the
government if you're a Muslim and you
don't feel safe because there are
islamophobes out there the British
government is ready to act on your
behalf but suppose you're a non-muslim
and you see Islam spreading and you see
Muslim preachers saying things like this
the best kind of death I can have is I
was fighting in the path of Allah and I
died a Shah the best that you can do is
Jihad the Jihad that we know of which is
fighting first and most and last goal is
to reestablish
that so very soon my dear brothers and
sisters we're going to see the kilaa
expand into Jordan into Saudi Arabia
onto the shores of Europe and one day
Obama he will witness his own country be
run by the Sy and inshallah one day we
will become Martyrs and there's going to
be more martyrs we're coming to power
we're coming to power this is how we
come to power Allah gives this religion
the dominance that he promised
it or I die in the process I die in
pursuit of that Allah subhanahu wa taala
says in the Quran what means and fight
against them until disbelief in Allah
subhanahu wa taala is no longer
dominant and until the religion all of
it is for for Allah it's impossible to
find someone who truly believes in Allah
and his messenger loves someone who
opposes Allah and his messenger
everything we represent goes in total
contradiction to what the West
represents the American government
secularism democracy capitalism these
are Cancers to hell with their
democracy Jews Christians as well as
alus they will be in the Hellfire
forever why because they are
the they are the worst of the creation
for example a cfir uhhuh a non-believer
a non-muslim yeah we hate him for the
sake of Allah subhana was explained by
and many
others is to love and to hate for the
sake of Allah which is simply summed up
as loving the Muslims and hating the
non-muslims you're telling that this
believer you're telling the people of
and kufur I don't like you I hate you
because Allah hates you the C those that
leave The Obedience of Allah and indulge
in their desires then says they are
worse than even animals those people
right the the misel the disbelievers
amongst the Jews and the Christians and
the
mush they will be in Hell Fire they will
be in Hell eternally and they are the
worst of the creatures are you allowed
to be
scared of course not you're a non-muslim
if you're scared it's because you're a
racist if you're scared it's because
you're a bigot if you're scared it's
because you're a hate Monger if you're
scared it's because you're an
islamophobe and you belong in
prison this two-tier system comes
straight out of the Quran Surah
98:6 verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam the Quran and Prophet
Muhammad blah blah blah from among the
people of the scripture Jews and
Christians and al- musun will abide in
the fire of hell they are the worst of
creatures Jews Christians and other
non-muslims are the worst of creatures
we're lower than dogs we're lower than
pigs we're lower than
insects so we're the worst of creatures
who are the best in Surah 3: 110 Allah
proclaims that mus Muslims are the best
of peoples Ever Raised up for
mankind Muslims are the best of peoples
non-muslims are the worst of creatures
That's the basis for the two-tier
culture and justice system in Muslim
countries and now it's the basis for the
two-tier culture and justice system in
Great Britain and since this two-tier
culture and justice system are
diametrically opposed to British law and
British values its adoption means the
destruction of Great Britain looks like
the Sun May finally set on the British
Empire and British values and British
people who for some reason keep voting
people like Kier starmer into power
[Music]